amy said to me after the table read
because you know for those who don't
know this amy is uh
i am i think i'm
nine perhaps 10 years older than amy but
amy was the mother of that set and she
was a mother to me she was a mother to
everybody on that set and she always
wanted to make sure we were good we were
comfortable and so after that table read
she comes up to me and she's like now
jim are you comfortable with this and i
go amy
i get to fart i get to split my pants i
was born for this this is absolutely
what i was born for but she was so
that's just who amy is i mean anyone who
knows her um she's incredibly kind and
she will forego
a very good funny bit if it would make
anybody uncomfortable that's that's just
who amy is
yeah again it all starts from the top
you know mike and greg great show
runners yeah and amy an amazing number
one and tell us a little bit about you
know how you started on the show i mean
it's kind of an interesting story
actually if i remember i don't know how
you got started i auditioned for ron
swanson uh like everybody else in la it
was you know there was heat around this
because it was the untitled amy poehler
project coming off of snl and the word
had gotten out it wasn't a pilot it was
straight to series you know a
six-episode order i believe if that's i
don't know if i'm correct about that but
anyway so there's you know so and the
way
you know typical jim o'hare fashion you
know i'm i can be down on myself like i
think a lot of actors and so i never in
a million years went in there thinking i
would get that uh but i did know it was
greg daniels and mike shore and i wanted
to impress them so that if there was
ever a guest star rolled on the line if
there was ever uh you know on the office
and maybe they would like me and
consider me you know just i've always
believed you're going you know you don't
know what the what else they're working
on so i went in i did my
you know my ron swanson version of of
what i thought do you remember your ron
swanson can you give us a little bit of
it i i wish i did i mean first of all
the thought of anyone
other than offerman i can't even i know
like my head can't go there um
i i'm sure it was i you know
i don't think i embarrassed myself
because i do remember leaving thinking
you did exactly what you wanted to do
because you know you can leave auditions
and you get in your car and you're like
son of a [ __ ] oh my god did i start or
you're reliving and i should have done
this i do remember thinking
wow such great guys in the room and you
know uh greg and mike and i remember
uh uh it was allison um
oh allison jones jones casting director
who of course guessed on this yet it's
just
the sweetest anyway so it was a lovely
room because actors go into a lot of
different rooms and they're not always
great rooms you know we've all we've all
been there and uh this was a great room
they were
you know and we i did have a little bit
of a um connection to chat with them
about because i you know worked with
corel in um chicago uh one of the last
gigs i did was a voice job with steve
and i did for i feel like it was miller
beer i don't know what the hell it was
for but anyway so it's always nice to
have something you can chat so we could
talk about carell a little bit and stuff
like that but i left the room thinking
this was good
not at all thinking ron swan seemed good
that they'd call me for that but these
guys like me and
maybe they'll have something down the
road
and then i think it was around two weeks
later they call and say
uh would jim consider reading for this
role of jerry
well of course so i go in and i get into
the waiting room and it's
fat guys thin guys tall guys short guys
uh they did not know you know they
didn't know who jerry was obviously at
that point
uh which is it's uh
it leaves the door open uh which is can
be good and bad
and so again i went in there and i they
created a scene and if i remember there
was no jerry material i think they
created some sides yeah they knew they
created this audition material
and i did it and again i felt really
good about the room i felt good about my
back and forth with mike and greg um
but again you leave and you have to let
it go because you know you never know
and then we get the call a couple weeks
later
and my agent goes jim they want to book
you on this on this untitled amy poehler
project and i go oh which role because i
really not that ever thought i was
getting around swanson but anyway so
needless to say it was jerry and then
what i loved what they did was they were
very honest
when they booked this they told my reps
that
uh we don't know what's going to happen
here we have six series regulars that we
have got to
you know cater to basically there are
there are people um
and so we don't know what's gonna happen
and that's why what i mentioned earlier
my agents were like maybe you don't want
to do this but again like i said it was
a no-brainer for me even if it didn't
even if i had done those six and walked
out the door
to have had that experience of even
those six episodes i would have no
regrets so the fact that it turned into
what it did and i'll never forget i was
in an airport in miami
and my manager calls and she said well
i just got a call and they would like to
negotiate to have you be a series
regular on parks and recreation and i
literally in a
some air you know some miami airport
screamed holy i don't know if we can
swear on this thing
oh we can do it it's mostly swears jake
and people are looking at me
uh
you know because i certainly wanted it
to go that way but it doesn't mean it's
going to just because i wanted it to so
that was kind of and then uh then all of
a sudden uh i'm a series regular on
parks and recreation so yeah you made
the right bed you made the right bedroom
and it's and it's really a testament to
you and your audition for ron because
people people don't know jim auditioned
for a run you know how wild is that to
think about you know